hi i'm megan from khan academy and in
this video we'll walk through the
reports related to assignments on khan
academy
after you've created assignments on khan
academy
and your students have completed those
assignments
you can track progress using a variety
of reports designed to help teachers
gain a deeper understanding of students
strengths and areas for opportunity
start by selecting the class from the
teacher dashboard
and then selecting scores under the
assignments tab in the left side
navigation
this will bring you to the assignment
scores report
in this report you will see progress
across assignments for all students in
the class if the assignment is a video
or article
and students have completed the
assignment you will see a green check
mark
to earn completion for a video the
student must have watched at least 90 of
the video at no faster than double speed
to earn completion for an article
the student must have clicked into the
article
if the assignment is an exercise quiz or
test
the student's best score will be shown
in a color-coded box
boxes appear as red for scores 0 through
59
yellow for scores 60 to 99 or green for
score of a
hundred if the student has not completed
the assignment
the box will remain gray
to access a more detailed report for an
individual assignment from the
assignment scores report select the
assignment name for any assignment that
contains questions
this includes exercises quizzes and
tests
this screen shows you an example of an
assignments responses report for an
exercise that contains seven questions
on the left side you can select the
first or last attempt students made to
answer the questions
you are also able to select each
question to see students responses
if you've chosen to provide different
questions for each student
the questions appear in the order
students found them most challenging
the question students answered
incorrectly most frequently appears at
the top
while the question students answered
correctly most frequently appears at the
bottom
if you've chosen to provide the same
question for all students
the questions appear in the order in
which they were presented to students
on the right side you can select a
specific student or the whole class to
view the assignment responses report
select the responses tab on the right to
see a summary of student responses
correct responses can be highlighted by
selecting the reveal answer button
you can view which students gave which
answers by selecting an individual
response to display student names
many teachers recommend keeping students
names private when sharing this report
with the entire class
you can select the draw tab to reveal a
scratch pad space that you can use to
solve the problem live with students
many teachers recommend using a
projector for the class to follow along
some teachers also suggest having a
student solve the problem step by step
for the class instead of the teacher
as a way to encourage student voice and
build student confidence
in the hints tab you can view the
step-by-step process to solve the
problem these are the same steps
provided to students in real time when
they select the get a hint option in an
exercise
you can also access the assignment
responses report by selecting the manage
tab from the class dashboard
and then selecting view report for the
individual assignment
the assignment scores report and the
assignment responses report
are helpful in monitoring assignment
progress for an entire class
if you'd like to look more closely at
the assignment progress for a single
student
use the individual student assignment
report
from the class dashboard select activity
overview from the left side navigation
then select the individual student whose
assignment progress you want to view by
selecting the student's name from the
class list
this brings you to the individual
student report
select the assignments tab to view all
assignments given to that student
this report displays the due date and
time
assignment name assignment status
attempts made on the assignment and the
student's best score if the assignment
is an exercise quiz or test
there is also a red indicator that
appears next to the assignment status if
the assignment is laid
meaning the student completed the
assignment after the due date
the individual student assignment report
can also be reached from the assignment
scores report
from the assignment scores report select
the student's name from the student list
in the assignment scores report
this will bring you to the student's
individual student assignment report
we hope this video helps you better
understand the assignment reports on
khan academy and how to best use these
reports to support student success